we should rip Baron Trump from his
mother's arms and put him in a cage with
pedophiles still up on Twitter by the
way right now no punishment but he
apologized but I'm sorry it's too late
go upstairs I don't care
over the past week was in another purge
obviously of canoe not only we seen this
of conservatives but we have seen
rejoicing from the left I'm delighted to
see this they're taking out the trash
these awful people mitigation
encouraging violence sanctioning
violence look you have no right to speak
on someone else's platform let Milo
UNESCO so let's go to geo cities or Mike
faces something he can't go on Facebook
Facebook and I think I agree a lot man's
like an anti-semitic cartoon it's a
company right we don't like regulation
than it should regulate itself look that
first guy was talking mr. honey la
nomar's watching it like I mean come on
we should just do this program like
cable news it would be so much easier to
be no prep hey what do you think sir
outrage and I'm sounding slightly like
Woody Allen crust with the Nutty
Professor from The Simpsons Milo you
napple Apple appleís I want to make sure
that I clear about this and Bill will
obviously help clarify this this is not
a this is not a freedom of speech issue
okay so before people yell private
company I want you to hear what we're
about to talk what we're about to
discuss and let's go over kind of the
new rules as to what is and isn't
allowed so just as important as kind of
understanding why and which conservators
are banned is looking at the behavior
that's routinely accepted from the left
so there have been clear terms of
service violations from the left things
I like doc saying things like
threatening people things like inciting
people to violence with no consequences
I wouldn't be really clear I don't want
any preferential treatment I don't think
any Consuela I do think some
conservatives do I'll have to get to
that in a second I just want to know the
rules and I think that's an important
distinction that people need to make
this either dishonest business practices
or not knowing where they'll end up and
not applying the law equally well I
think through the even just the point in
our own experience has been the company
is often unclear left hand right hand
about what the rules are right even
day-to-day even your encounter rules
handling the same videos being handled
differently in different times by
different people raised that there's a
level of subjectivity that means that
when the company is out there selling it
platform as a in reality it's be and
that is when you get to the heart of a
fraud that they're using to build a
business platform on them and people
choose to use the platform's and spend
money on those platforms that give their
data valuable data do these companies
thinking that they're getting something
that they're really clearly don't honor
their own rules so just in case you
think that you think I'm making some
democratic state representative we'll
talk with Dan Crenshaw about this in a
second Brian Sims you guys see this
where he videotaped himself
I don't know video tape as a term
anymore people just realized how video
itself he cell feed himself which sounds
redundant harass and young girls and old
ladies praying outside of abortion
clinics and offered money to anyone who
would Docs them lest you think I'm
making it up hi everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I am
outside the Planned Parenthood at
southeastern Pennsylvania now they're
leaving now
a bunch of pseudo Christian protesters
who don't need to look clear an elected
official or a reason money to anyone who
would Doc's pro-life prayer volunteers
you could live the rest of your life
with singular purpose and unbelievable
focus in an attempt to and and still not
accomplish anything that shitty do it
volunteer bazoobs
oh my gosh pseudo Christians pseudo
Christian because my point of view
that's also Alexander Cortez he would
tell me the contest was talking about
this week she says millions of people
don't know anything about women's bodies
from other Georgia bill say well Hoss
time do you know anything about women's
bodies alright after six weeks the
reason it's called a heartbeat bill
because you're stopping the heartbeat
whose heartbeat is that I can I not
understand that because I'm a man or do
I actually just understand you're the
party of science that if you have two
hearts you are a medical marvel someone
get bend cars
this guy by the way this is what's also
really egregious here is he took the
video and it didn't yeah
videotape himself he streamed on a
periscope when my in my day a periscope
was when you took some milk cartons
Twitter so this guy obviously feared no
consequences that's what bothers me
Daxing by the way in targeted harassment
expressly outlined as Banda Belov ences
yeah and Twitter's terms of seems pretty
clear and they should be this isn't an
isolated incident remember Peter Fonda
the actor he calls for Baron Trump to be
abducted and raped by pedophiles lest
you think I'm exaggerating again and I
know my half-asian where bill Lishman
gets he gets a little uncomfortable you
know I'm going too far under these this
is a quote Peter for Easy Rider was
beautiful not easy ready yes yeah okay
we should rip Baron Trump from his
mother's arms and put him in a cage with
pedophiles and see if mother will stand
up against the giant ass she is married
to now I know at first glance that seems
pretty cut and dry I don't know what to
believe anymore he's still up on Twitter
by the way right now no punishments a
good face but he apologized but I'm
sorry it's too late go upstairs I don't
care there's so many things that they
have done that that would under under
this the band that just happened would
easily have gotten them kicked off this
is also it's important it's also illegal
that's something people need to
understand threat actually making a
threat of violence or inciting people to
violence you yeah this whole idea you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater you
actually can yeah if there's a fire in a
if there's not I believe a legal term is
fraud and we commonly refer this as
lying yeah right the thing is if you try
to respect two laws they don't abide by
the laws we have people who sign consent
we have people who say I agree to appear
on camera changed my mind and then go to
youtube say I don't want to be on there
anymore and you two makes us blur it we
swirl first off it's a single party
consent state we're not breaking the law
and we don't show you them giving
formation acuteness I don't care because
I just want to deal with the problems
that is the issue these these offenses
are actually illegal by the way hit the
notification bell actually just bookmark
the channel on YouTube because
notifications may not work join up a lot
of credit
my club and of course you can leave a
rating there on iTunes so let's compare
this with what gets a ban on the right
in direct contrast leniency given to
left isn't to have anything right or
wrong so far legally no I actually was
gonna say that the exact other point
would be probably people would hear the
end of the first comment and say okay so
what's your position that they should be
allowed to say these things that they
should be allowed to say two things and
the point being that there's a disparity
right the whole point is yeah people are
being treated differently not because of
you know the certain what they're saying
it's because of the view that is being
espoused by whether it's right
several the accounts were banned I think
this within the last two weeks
the Acacio accorded the parity account
James word has suspended the Mogga
phobia account which was very surprising
to me it attract violence against
conservatives it's like it's like a
block parent someone videotaping an aunt
if a person punching a know lay in the
facing hey watch out for that guy you're
banned what cuz you upset the old lady
trying to start going wrong she was
really upset
exactly and paper-thin reasons were
given for example the the parody account
of Cortes would clearly fit the
guidelines it was Twitter policy parody
accounts are allowed yeah they it was
clear that it was a problem what I'm not
writing Twitter said the account was
seen as misleading going a little too
close to the source material I see
Bernie's thoughts it's hard for me to
tell the difference yeah sometimes I
have to undo the retweet because i
retweeted thinking I'm dunking on
senator Sanders oh it's not him he
really sounded like he was that mad yeah
and then of course Facebook and
Instagram they they banned people like
my lil innopolis Paul Joseph Watson
which I really don't understand the Paul
Joseph Watson though when he get put in
that list well they clearly violated the
dangerous individual to policy you're
dangerous they're a legal precedent
there for dangerous individuals is that
a law no I mean they they have their own
policies right and those policies
sometimes they you know deign to give us
a definition of them sometimes they
don't those definitions often change
it's possible that they have drawn from
some statute but it's not expressly
referenced so no okay the policy itself
does not refer to any particular law
it's when it says dangerous well what's
really dangerous to me ironically here's
they say someone like Gavin McGinnis
designated dangerous individual cat face
book and now they're saying that anyone
who associates with these people could
also be dangerous individual I don't
know how far that necessarily extends
obviously Gavin has been as been a
colleague right work together but then
we've had people on this show who we
don't agree with at all is that
considered association the rules are
never clear this is the platform that
actually banned any pictures of anyone
even seen wearing our socialism's four
fig shirts which by the way can be
purchased at letters cutter shop that
come along this wonderful new D platform
this crest t-shirt that's the crown I
love that one but we retro actively
photoshopped all of those pictures with
the socialism's for fake shirts to abide
by the twitter Terms of Service so as
you can see always thinking one step
ahead now here's one thing to a lot of
people see that they see any right-wing
critique of social media companies as
hypocritical again if you aren't clear
about what your problem is
conservatives are like it's not the
government's job to regulate private
business but then as soon as they feel
like they're not getting enough retweets
suddenly it's like we're launching an
investigation we've got a nationalized
tech companies long live socialism I
love how that clip was dead silent until
you could actually hear the applause
break carton coming up the platy fine I
know what to do I mean I can't use the
affirmative action comedy central hire
but we thought he'd make it easier for
us to play along we don't want to
nationalize social now and this is my
proposed solution this is really why I
wanna I want to get pills taken this
this allows all parties to freedom to
choose okay and and I think it just
needs to be as simple as a question
needs to be answered officially legally
on the record these social media
companies a court of law
they need to decide whether their
platforms or publishers because those
two things are very very different a
publisher someone at the New York Times
or even louder with Cotter or this
channel they can monitor content publish
on their site they can take they have to
take responsibility for if they
published a famine Tory information or
they incite violence they can be sued
for that because they're responsible for
the content a platform which would be
more like say a cell phone company they
provide a network they don't monitor
they don't censor your calls okay now
the reason that people have refer to
these social media companies in a
come to know them as platforms is
because they've legally been afforded
some of those rights not granted to a
publisher and what are those somebody
might be asking ones to protect them
from being sued as long as they operate
as a platform so if someone tweets for
example something to fam'ly Tory about
me like I don't know puts on a fake Nazi
sitter can't be sued for that as long as
they're a platform but that means if
they're a platform this is all I
understand that bill is going to correct
me here
they cannot determine which point of
views are allowed disallowed pick sides
or try to determine winners and losers
just based on point of view there's a
difference when a publisher and a
platform and I think that lately they've
been acting in a way they'll put them
firmly in the territory of publisher and
people don't know the rules the idea is
that is the tool doing it or is it the
person controlling it and if you're not
controlling the tool then the person who
is is the one that's in trouble so it's
the publisher the one who's putting the
message out and the person who is just
the phone line the tool provider the
platform there has to be a protection of
that because otherwise there would be no
financial incentive to be for example
any kind of platform to provide those
kind of tools if a criminal you know
orders a drug deal over a cell phone
does that mean that we should punish the
cell phone companies because they should
be controlling it no and in that same
way the the companies have changed
recently Jack Dorsey actually admitted
surprisingly in an interview that he
found himself to be a public marketplace
of ideas and then was talking about his
determination has a company that they
should be censoring and again censoring
not in the constitutional sense but
censoring him is in the idea of how
they're gonna limit what the ideas are
so they are actively choosing it by
actively choosing they've crossed that
threshold from just a neutral platform
to a publisher who's choosing the
messages they want to put out there and
they should be they should be helping so
you do that do they should would they be
called to testify does there need to be
a hearing my point is I think before we
get to any kind of regulation is give
them the opportunity to answer make them
choose declare publisher or a platform
in which case I think we'd be talking
with like public utility laws what would
that be some of it could be within the
courts right so the existing law that's
out there people have asked this
question over the years it's not you
know sound like oh just all of a sudden
2019 people asking this question right
but in the past it's been different and
we can see it's change it's been in a
creative change over the years where now
they are far
over the line it's also very important
to conservatives out there if we if we
do this and this this is I think the
route that we should take again comment
let me know that means that if you're a
conservative you're gonna have to accept
these rules for everybody so don't break
the law right don't don't criminally
trespass right in the videotapes um I'm
use that word again
film someone on their private property
and then claim that you're being but
please don't do that because you can
film in a public area in a single party
consistent you cannot go into someone at
home or on their lawn and film them
they're just like you can't put out
there a false meme that you know to be
false to harm somebody just because you
don't like them and that means
conservatives are going to have to allow
Ilhan Omar Farrakhan to post all the
anti-semitic crap they want by that same
token Twitter
you can't allow Hamas to recruit people
so at that point when we say you're a
platform then at least we know okay you
have to at least there has to be some
semblance of abiding by the law for
which all of us can have reasonable
expectations right now there are there's
their rule set and then there's law and
sometimes you you can be obeying one in
breaking the other for example Peter
Fonda hoping that Barron Trump's get
raped raped by pedophiles yeah you would
think oh I don't know that seems like
we're a okay
AOC parody we're a little murky on the
legality at that point yet I just want
to know what the rules are and I think
that's what conservatives need to be
pushing for not locking arms
hand-in-hand with people like Pelosi and
people like Cortes who also want
sweeping regulation of these guys yeah
and I think it's important to people to
understand the legality of it and
understand the difference in a platform
and a publisher and by the way I'm like
what we talked about Bill Bar with Dan
Crenshaw we have to get to him he
probably waiting for us um this it's
he's he's an under no requirement to
speak with more lawyers by the way he
there are no requirement to provide a
completely unrelated report to the
public and or all members of Congress
Congress this is a legally relevant
question here unlike the bar situation
because I know people will accuse the
left in the right Nam and you're always
playing politics no no we just want some
clarity we're calling for more
transparency not less I think that's
pretty important because again when you
talk about sweeping national legislation
it's not about Donald Trump right now
again the Mogga hot wearing people who
just like to troll no there's gonna be
someone else in office after President
Donald Trump so let's
try and take some steps in the right
direction allowing for more freedom not
less the good news here is we can
actually take a first step
low cost requires very little
bureaucratic red tape or any kind of
overall right away it only requires the
truth
it requires social media companies to
put their money where their mouth is and
if they want to continue to benefit from
the umbrella and the legal protection of
a platform fine or do they want to
remove it edit and censor content based
on point of view like a publisher this
can all start with just two yes-or-no
questions and all it's needed for the to
start revolution really right now in
fairness and transparency and honesty is
to get these big tech CEOs the owners in
the hot seat and all that's required is
to get them to answer yes or no this
video this is the part where I would
usually tell you to subscribe but I
can't do it anymore I'm gonna tell you
to subscribe and then YouTube is going
to decide that we can't reach you even
though you subscribe to this channel and
then I'll say hit the notification bell
and then the notification Bell won't
even be there anymore I don't know what
to say more than likely you'll find my
face in a milk carton but do what you
can to stop it it's just that it's just
it probably won't do much